I want to ask you because you actually
think about behavioral trends what's
going on this is something you give
thought to for example the the naked
celebrity selfies that are out there and
I thought maybe you could explain what's
going on maybe you could tell us in your
opinion yeah I understand I'm taking
them but why are they posting them I'm
not I got to say if I look like Jennifer
Lawrence I'd be posting them all the
time but but I don't understand why
they're posting them on this cloud thing
do you trust the cloud oh god no I don't
know what's the cloud the thing is
there's no naked photo of me anywhere
there's I've never taken a photo of
myself or naked or oh I'm sure yeah
it would break the phone yeah no one
wants to see me nude and I'm not I don't
like the idea of like being naked and
taking a picture of myself but I think
that's a generational thing I don't know
oh I understand I haven't that you will
never if you ever see a naked picture of
me online it's a fake I have never taken
a naked selfie so I don't know if you're
getting ready to pop one out but it's
[ __ ]
which both of you why do you think I
would have a maker how egotistical do
you have to be dr. Phil that I would
have a naked selfie of you loaded up and
ready to go yeah well good asked you
take me for cuz I just know how you jerk
me around every time I come here friends
we're pals were amigos I've never do
anything like that to you
[Applause]
I nearly wasn't telling me something I
knew it you're talking about happened to
your genitals
I tell you I know I wouldn't even let I
wouldn't even let him put a shiny floor
in my bathroom that's how much I don't
want to yeah I know I'm with you on that
I know I don't have but I there is a
younger thing now where actually I think
they don't intend to share these naked
selfies they don't intend to for other
people to see them and what they texted
to one person to wind up on the cloud
yeah funny how that happens what do you
mean but isn't it funny how it's always
the really good-looking people that they
get hacked I mean is that really an act
they don't put their pictures of that no
I think there are unattractive people
who are putting selfies up everywhere
and no one's hacking into them no one
want I could put up a nude selfie of me
tomorrow and it would not go in I've
tried I've tried to put them out there
yeah I put hundreds of them on that yeah
well I'm sure that piece of [ __ ] is put
up all over the Internet within minutes
I'm sure no no no we'll make sure that
no one gets all confident that that's
gonna be yeah no not at all not at all
those things don't go viral
you